Yeah
The streets have always been watching Gotham has been waiting patiently for the Mecca to regain its rightful aller
In the heart of Harlem Rises not just a savior, but a moon
The city game now reborn is generating a tidal wave of president future stars a Brotherhood defined by two words
unveiling the next brand of hoax in NYC
The jelly fan phenomenon to describe it within New York City on steroids and
2k 17 social media
Is a group of young men who have changed the culture of basketball
Everybody in the city, they like somebody who's positive once we started getting popular. Jelly came took the world by storm
Noumic trashin going gonna back up you should back up swallow say I'm handsome. I got my bezel
The slide is just like you just gotta have you gotta be born with it most of us in here
We like to draw attention to crowds. You know everybody sees us, or like kind of like rock stars everybody making the tri-state lit
It's the dawn of a new age for New York City basketball
Revitalized by a group of young dynamic players who have taken the big athlete by storm
Their indoor and outdoor stages are filled with packed houses and celebrity Road
Isaiah and the whole jelly fan movement has definitely kept players in New York City the CHS AAA which is the Catholic High School League?
That we're currently in
Abroad New York City has never had the crowds that it has had
That Goldman what's happening country right now?
I'm gonna show you I got a problem coming no that themselves from your boy Esau told Amy
Jelly-filled
I
Stay at Washington the current Minnesota gopher is the co-creator of the jelly fan movie?
named after Isaiah's signature finger roll move
Jelly is a finger room, but you know you just got to add your own little spice to it I
Made judging my own signature move
Because I saw it might be Jordan do the open legs dump right now John dad said dump
So I just had to add some jelly and just open my leg
It's the most infamous layup on the planet right now
Just like all in the flick of the wrist. I was like you get it
You kind of got a lick the defendant in his eyes and cock it back and then
Let it go
We were sitting in my house, then I'm looking on my phone
And you like you know everybody said fam and fam this and we always would say jelly-like anytime somebody later ball up like jelly
Naima Lett yeah, we need our own group. I was just sitting in and I'm like yo
Jelly Finn say your eyes. You know he got big eyes and visa yo room Chile Finn. That'd be late. Yeah
As Washington is required James countless evolved so did decides that they're growing hoop fraternity
through their tri-state
New York City connections the dual added several of their friends who just so happened to be some of the best players in the region
We was all in the same team me jock quit I was there Pedro
I was on Instagram when I say I changed name to each other feel underscored um John
She wasn't jealous for most coach John. I was like what is that?
They hit me up about it like I'm starting this movement
And then um I got I got in the gym with on one time, and they was just playing around with it
I'm just watching him do it. I'm like
Oh, that's hot we could really do something with this
And it was like that's the new move movie starting cuz they are I want I want to join it
He's like he's like you got to beat jellies in the game you down alright so the next game
Their one jelly I looked at them like it's coming like I got two more. I'm more. I'll be down there
I'll do the other two in the game and then after the game. I'll change my name to jelly from ones course
It's been maybe nice ever since
We all have like a special layup
We all can finish around the basket and numerous ways, and they chose me as one of them
and I'm proud to be a part of
Most of us are like top players in that town
Around the country in how everybody's gonna be like this like a brotherhood. Just like more the basketball
Look at it like owner of the cost of VG's what each other accountable basically
We just all came together as like brothers and sent me be an only girl
And we just aspired the basketball world from younger kids, Isaiah, Washington being my best friend
He told me that I was the best girl in New York City people I should be
Recognized just as they were by us doing the jelly and Isaiah
They answer another level in New York it just
Took over the whole entire tri-state, and it definitely put New York back on a map
Put your boy
Jelly fam members became staples around both the summer circuits and the tri-state Catholic High School leaves
with members playing with and against each other
We all think that tele fam Iranian jelly can be the best
We don't think anybody's better than us
So we're going at each other as if we are the best
Those matchups are just crazy just cuz of the names people want to see us play against each other these guys are competitive sometimes
I'm thinking about to come to blows, but they just go hard you just compete
I don't think there's like a better atmosphere than New York City summertime basketball
in the Urich our motto if you put him on an island you got a drown - meaning like if his one-on-one with somebody you've
Got to get a buck
Rucker they were just like all right we need you and him to go at each other like make the crowd go crazy
I thought as soon as I came in
Me him started guard each other. He was going back and forth scoring on each other
I remember him coming down the right side of the floor going meadow and then stepping back and the tough jump shot in my face
The crowd went crazy suddenly I got a fire back with song JQ came down. I think he liked a few legs hurt
I didn't think he's gonna do a 360 like I thought he's gonna try it late crowd going crazy like everybody's standing up
I remember it was just like an instinct. I just jumped up 360 and he had flew past me and then
When it went in like the part just went a while
Harry Winer Crowley nuts, and I was even looking like well
He really just did that I was nice. I told him I said that was totally Lucas throwing basketballs
It was a people running the court IP we taking his shirt off. It was
As the jelly fan Brotherhood started piling up legendary performances the group discovered
They possess something of far greater values. They had developed an authentic brand with fans recording every moment
The movements voice was soon spread nationwide
Jelly fan will because of social media and allows you to share it on Facebook Twitter things like that really to be honest we just
Expanded it because it was Guinness Girls
social media definitely social media is
Probably the number one reason that this thing has caught fire and those guys have done a great job of marketing
Anytime there's an announcement that he is going to play at a certain venue that the park is almost overrun
Almost like the whole school Rucker games kids are hanging on the fence as it had a found impact on summer basketball
Mainly because he has swag to his game and the great part about him is that he backs it up
Two balls up
Damn
One day I crub up the Dyckman cuz the high school games the last couple years been more popping in on limited games
so jelly fair was playing and
the crowd the park was packed
Hey everybody
Everybody knows about if you can't go anywhere country that people recognize y'all
He was like well like all of this came from us being a great one to make a group and now it's like a whole
Thing everybody across the country wants it be Joseph, but we'll miles a lot of kids
and we have to like carry ourselves the right way act like what kind of professionals because
Everybody's watching us we can't go anywhere without taking pictures now
I did like we could be anywhere in a little kill going to you like oh you're such a from the other film
Can I get the picture?
So good
I'll give you something
I'm gonna be to get a girl like that. Oh, man. You gotta get older man here. Take this way
Lower fund up say China I
Jelly fam co-created require James has witnessed up close the growth of a brand moving before as
The nephew of rap star Juelz, Santana he observed his uncle father and superstar hip-hop artist Cam'ron
aggressively and successfully grow their diplomats music label
Growing up and being around the music business and stuff like that. It shows you that like everything coincides together like
Music and basketball is like one thing fashion and music and fashion in basketball
Job was always a special kid he always seemed like he was one of us already even at that age
The whistle video during that time even being so young he always it's just like
walk in the room and just
Get the attention of everybody and we fight. It's what I do. That's that was his attitude and I'm saying
We had to kind of like okay plan chop was a grown man at 3 years old
You know he's been around the diplomats is our prom and his father's a cool guy. That's uncle Joseph, ooh
God so he got a lot of cool being young my career was kind of taking off at the same time
So I just kind of kept y'all close with me and just you never really treating him like a kid
He was always just treating him like he's one of us
He was around and seen us fight file labeled file own
Company at first nobody wants to sod you Ellis nobody want to signed you so what I did was saying look we fly
We know how to route be out of great image
Let's put out a mixed a where the first
Artist that made our own mixtape to say we don't need to DJ and it worked even fit
He said followed the format
And he started making g-gonna mixtape and people started loving the g-unit mixtapes zsa was around order
He's seen the Rilla marketing if I know we go into a basketball game
Yo, let's all promote it from this Sunday
Even if there's two weeks from now cuz now everybody gonna see it so now when we come to the gym the gym is fully
Packed everybody there without we returned in topic for the next week
Now we do the same thing for another game or another high school game that we plan in
Return the topic for another week and now it's like oh jellyfish jelly fam and everybody just keeps seeing it now
That's where we at today
As jelly fan begins to make its mark on the national stage the group feels the brand stock will rise
Now the one collar that's even more publicity meaning more fans, so I think it's gonna get bigger and bigger
Multiple of us make its den be everything we could have a brand in the future potentially
Create our own story like I think sky is the limit. I think we all gonna go to the NBA I
Believe that we're gonna make our own brand have own company want to be like get out there get out there once
We're like free and adults. I think this thing is gonna blow up
Being around my uncle being around cam like you see them like they always had their own
Customized clothing news customized sneaker just stuff like that just makes you want to be creative now
I want to have like eventually like in the future. I want to have our own sneaker like a jelly famous shoe
This is pretty incredible out on her
gang movements
Drug movements music movements of
radical party movements
Black panther white supremacist whatever he wanted me
But for these kids to come together and treat a basketball movement as great marketing
And I don't even know that they realize how good marketing was from my coach
He always told me you're gonna be getting walking when you get to college. I just hit them laughs but
Think about it like I could really I would just kill it
There's something we never see what they're doing is they're paving the way for basketball crews
Now could be a different city or growing up underneath them or
Whether they recruit you for me to perceive to be part of jelly-filled whatever they're doing is genius. I'll tell you that is genius
And I should and I'm gonna go
I
This is every Rock
We meet up